- I never talked about this. For three—
Even in Toronto.
My dad got sick Christmas 2018.
My last year in Toronto,
my dad got sick. Went to the hospital.
I flew home
a couple days before Christmas,
sat with my dad, and he was in the hospital
for the next—in and out of the hospital
the next three years after that.
So for three years,
I flew from Boston to L.A.,
L.A. to Toronto
by myself, played in the game.
Did the same thing in San Antonio. And nobody
never knew. It was times that I flew
in the day of the game and played.
From seeing my dad.
- So, leave L.A.,
fly in game day and play
that night.
- That night.
I did it so many times, countless times.
I never talked about it.
Never talked about it.
- I mean, how difficult was that
when you were making these trips
and then having to go to work?
- It was, it was, it was the most—
It was probably the hardest thing
in my life to do because you know, you,
you, you have so much idle
time of sitting on a plane by yourself,
dealing with the emotional, like,
like, trauma of seeing your dad,
seeing a person that—only person in life
I ever feared—you know, down and out,
to having to go play
in front of 20,000 people.
You know, it was like
the emotional roller coaster
that I dealt with for,
you know, three years was,
was one of the toughest things ever
because, one, I never wanted to be
a distraction to my teammates,
to the game and nothing.
So I dealt with everything
I dealt with personally,
and I didn't want to be loud about it.
I didn't want nobody necessarily
feel sorry for me and everything,
but I also wanted to be there
for my teammates and my family.
You know what I mean? So to carry
those emotions consistently,
you know, behind the scenes
and nobody knew, you know, it was, it was,
it was tough. It was tough.
Like, even, even when I lost my dad,
I was in a hotel in Charlotte.
Just finished playing a game. Fly home.
You know, home a couple of days.
And I flew back with the team to play in
a game. Fly back home. Go to his funeral.
Leave shootaround. Go play in a—
You know, it was like
all those emotions to where–
And then what really made it hard,
you know, like I said, I'm sitting
on a plane by myself for hours, like,
you know, with this on your mind
trying to figure out how,
how are you going to balance yourself
out to be able to play tonight?
You know? But I needed to play.
Like I said, my teammates, guys
I played with knew
what I was going through,
and they was always there for me,
and they made it easy for me, and that's why
I always felt like I had to be there
for them as well to compete.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, that was for three years.